[Music]
united in tribute to a pacemaker the
irish president and the british prime
minister both came to pay their respects
lord trimble the original first minister
of northern ireland afforded more honor
in death than he had been in life
lady trimble heard her late husband
described as a man of courage and vision
therefore children did the readings
peace i leave with you
my peace i give you
i do not give to you as the world gives
do not let your hearts be troubled and
do not be afraid
as ulster unionist leader david trimble
and his nationalist counterpart john
hume were the architects of the good
friday agreement
they shared the nobel prize for peace
but with both now gone the
responsibility has passed to a new
generation
former sinn fein leader jerry adams was
in the congregation but its first
minister designate michelle o'neil now
facing the challenges
with political leaders from all sides in
attendance there was an impassioned play
for the restoration of power sharing at
stormont
can we use this service today
in a fitting tribute to one of the great
to redouble our efforts on this island
home of ours
may our politicians engage
wholeheartedly
in resolving the outstanding issues
surrounding the northern ireland
protocol
so that our democratic institutions are
quickly restored
and we can all move forward
together
former teacher bertie ahern said david
trimble had stepped up to help end 30
years of violence in northern ireland
history will remember him as the man who
compromised to save countless lives
david blevins sky news in lisbon